it is a um it's an anniversary
and i want to talk about something of
which cassandra is like a foremost
expert on
waco right yes but first check this out
this is this is mind-blowing and i
wonder if you know this took cassandra
today or i'm sorry yesterday the atf
tweeted we remember the fallen agents
conway conway lebloo special agent todd
mckeon
special agent robert williams special
agent steve willis who made the ultimate
sacrifice
trying to execute a search warrant learn
more remember waco
february 28 1993. now
cassandra that tweet triggers you right
i am taking deep breaths wait wait
reading it got me mad all over again did
you know that in 2020
they tweeted the same thing yeah and i
think i flipped out last year
and you know the year before that they
tweeted the same thing
yeah so ever since i made my twitter
account i think in 2013
or something every single year on waco
i've gone into like
long thread rant crazy person because
i've been obsessed with waco since i was
little
i remember seeing it on the news i think
i was like eight years old
and it was horrifying so break down
what happened for everybody who doesn't
who's not super friendly government
murdered our kids
basically um no what actually happened
was
the branch davidians were living in a
compound in waco texas obviously
and atf and fbi had just flubbed
massively uh a raid on ruby ridge
and they shot a woman who was holding
her 10 month old baby
their 14 year old son while trying to
like stake out and arrest this guy
and so everybody was really pissed off
about it everybody was like
enraged and atf looked bad fbi looked
bad people were really angry at them
so they were like let's get a win let's
go and save these kids from this bad
evil cult and so david crush the leader
of the branch davidians he would
jog into town every day he was close to
local sheriff
the people there were all
you know easily accessible friendly with
the community the sheriff loved
him they called him when they were
getting raided but um
they wanted to make a big spectacle
about arresting david crush because he
had some illegal gun parts
they sold stuff at gun shows it was you
know whatever
gun control yeah so us government gun
control is really scary
so basically what happened is on
february 28 1993
they went and they were gonna go serve a
warrant but they wanted it to be flashy
they wanted to have a big
blowout and so they invited the local
news to come
well the local news driver got lost and
he
asked a usps driver how to get to
the mount caramel which was the branch
davidian compound
and that guy happened to be a branch
davidian so
he warned everybody who was back at the
compound
that something was going wrong and
something was weird was happening
so they all got ready and
they didn't come out and they weren't
going to come out and so
atf breached the top window there's very
famous video of them going up on a
ladder
and a shootout took place inside so
members of the atf were killed
and they retreated and a standoff ensued
for 51 days
where they were torturing the people
inside um
there were i think 27 women 25 children
who died but um for 51 days they
tortured these people
they would play sounds of of uh rabbits
being slaughtered which is a horrific
sound
like really loud through the speakers
they wouldn't give them milk
they turned off the electricity there
were a lot of babies in there
and they couldn't eat so they made a
deal to give them milk but then they put
like recording devices in it
it was just really bad they wait they
did things
there that would be considered a war
crime if we did it in another nation
and then ultimately in april it
culminated with
a cs gas attack they they went and they
told janet reno that
they believed that david crush was
beating babies and raping babies none of
which was true
he had married a 14 year old but that
was legal in texas at the time
i personally disagree with that as most
people would
but it was legal and so
none of this was true they admitted like
five months after the siege that this
wasn't true
but because she they told her that
babies were being like
beaten she was like okay go in with cs
gas
and the fbi
the few sympathetic negotiators were
like
they're not going to have gas masks for
kids and
you know the fbi were like well they'll
have to come out faster then
so on the final day they started
piercing the building with tanks
and shooting cs gas in which
by this point the government knew was
flammable we had seen
the move bombing and several other raids
that ended up
turning buildings into bombs because
you're putting gas into a building and
breaking it apart
and they didn't have the fire department
there so the building caught fire
there's a debate if
if it was um the atf that started the
fire or if it was the branch civilians
but either way they did not have the
fire department there to stop it
and so the women and children went and
hid in a half-buried bus
and because the tanks were knocking down
the building
the door to get out got barricaded and
so they shot tear gas into where the
women and children were
and they died they suffocated
the whole building went up in an inferno
only a few people made it out
it's one of the the greatest american
tragedies in my opinion
okay sorry that was really long no no
and i'm sure there's a whole bunch
that was the quick version that was a
few minutes yeah and then every every
year
the atf on twitter commemorates the the
fallen servicemen
over what was probably one of the
most horrific atrocities and they never
say anything about the women or children
or
or men who were killed in there but you
know what the branch davidians do
every year they have a memorial at mount
carmel
and they also remember the atf who died
wow along with their own people the atf
doesn't do that i mean i
i i feel for the atf the families of
these men who lost their lives
sure but we clearly know who was in the
wrong on this one yeah you know i i'm
sad when i hear about war and i hear any
like people and i don't i don't want
anyone to die you know what i mean
it's my issue is that they
only remember the atf people there were
27 children
in there two unborn babies yep and
they killed them whether whether koresh
started the fire or not
which i personally don't believe but you
know that's their theory
even if that's true they were shooting
cs gas into a building did not have the
fire department on standby
knowing that it starts fires and they
could have arrested him anytime he
jogged into town
and they didn't because they wanted to
show for the cameras this was
all on them and they they don't even
memorialize the the babies that they
killed it infuriating
they'd have to admit that they killed
these children yeah the other thing too
is even outside of fire
it you don't fire cs gas into a closed
building because
it displaces oxygen right yeah i was in
turkey
and there was a parking garage it was
during gezi park and they were
very liberally using tear gas as it were
just like
there were so much tear gas on the
ground you were walking and kicking cans
out of the way
and i remember seeing a bunch of the
activists running into a parking tunnel
and then when the when the police fired
tear gas into it the next thing we saw
was a bunch of people dragging bodies
out
as soon as they that gas filled the
whole space up there's no air anymore
people were just dropping to the ground
so what did the atf think was going to
happen if they started firing tear gas
into a closed building
well they claimed that it would make the
women want to protect their children and
run out with their babies
but you know they had been terrorizing
these people for 51 days why would they
trust them to leave the building
yeah if i was them i would have thought
they were going to kill me
right so they were and they did yeah
yeah yeah so i was talking to somebody
about this on the anniversary and
they were like well that sounds like it
was handled you know less than
responsibly i was like yeah
and and i was like this is worse than
war because this is the government of
your own country
taking you out i was like i admittedly
that was the first time i had looked
into it was the other day
yesterday on the anniversary and i was
horrified i found pictures i saw like
the you know the fire
the chart remains yeah and i i sent that
picture and i was like i mean look at
this
you can tell me what you want the
government bulldozed that whole site
like a week later too
wow they didn't even like go and collect
all the evidence they were like let's
just get rid of this
like quite literally that's crazy yeah
my dad's from waco
i get infuriated yeah my dad's in my
family is from waco so
there's like nothing really related to
that because they all
i think they left well before you know
1993
yeah but apparently there was you know a
lot of stories of people who knew people
and like how crazy it was
david thibodeau who's one of the people
who who escaped from the fire
he has a book called waco survivor story
i cannot recommend this book enough it's
what the paramount and netflix
donkey drama was based on partially gary
nosner the fbi negotiator
he also wrote a book and they merged the
two books to make the series
but he's one of the nicest guys i've
ever talked to i've interviewed him and
i just think he is such a
a wonderful person and it breaks my
heart that they killed the woman that he
loved you know it
it's all very sad i i highly recommend
that book
or the paramount series to anyone who
wants to learn more about week
didn't bill barr do something where he
like he got someone off
yeah he defended them saying that they
were doing the right thing
and now i mean i was screaming my head
off when bill maher got put in the admin
i was like
no that kind of makes sense now so so i
have to ask what happened to janet reno
what happened to
anybody was there ever any
accountability well i mean
besides that she's getting uh the same
fiery treatment she gave those kids
that's fair i like that
yeah that makes sense now that that
makes trouble sorry but she was never
held accountable no
oh my god of course not cool yeah when
does that stuff ever happen
yeah yeah i i i think it's funny as i
read more and more like
gun blogs you know i'm like learning
about you know more about guns living in
the middle of nowhere and also buying
weapons
and it's funny how many comments i see
about the atf and the jokes and the
memes
and the mockery about how like the laws
make no sense
this one's too short but it's also too
long so it can't exist
and then there's i watched a video from
demolition ranch where he talks about
the absurdity of this weapon that's like
a it's a it's a shotgun but it's not a
shotgun so it's technically illegal but
it's not
it's just these people when that when
they're there
it's let me put it this way gun control
makes no sense
when they claim that the same gun in
like different styles
it becomes illegal if it if it's got
like a pistol grip versus a rifle grip
but it's the exact same weapon firing
the exact same thing at the exact same
rate
there's a lot of people who point out
how gun control seems to target
scary weapons as opposed to actually
functional weapons and then you end up
with atf raids going after people for
things that
should not be illegal or quite literally
makes no sense yeah it's hard to know
like it's hard to know if you're
accidentally breaking the law because
the laws are changing all the time
and they're doing well that's one thing
donald trump did luke complains about it
all the time
the bomb stock ban yeah made people
criminals overnight without notice like
i'm sure there were a lot of people who
had no idea what's going on politically
great
and they probably might have a bump
stock sitting in you know in their shed
not realizing it
and they don't know what they bought
maybe they got a bunch of different guns
and stocks and then they pass this law
this guy doesn't watch the news and now
what now he's a felon
and if they go to his house they're
going to find it he's going to go to
prison or get fined or
they could throw tear gas in his house
and kill his kids yeah i mean yeah
depending on
the degree to which this person has
these these items i kind of find it
strange that it's alcohol
tobacco and firearms all together and
explosives like why
alcohol why tobacco what does tobacco
have anything to do with guns
it's weird to me like why would you just
call it the f get rid of the other
make different
like get tobacco out of there doesn't it
i understand the contraband running in
the 20s when did they start the atf was
it like the late 20s yeah so weird when
was tobacco contraband
yeah yeah oh just in in the us i don't
know they really do got to change the
gates you have to be honest
yeah like they should get rid of the ats
abolish the 18th abolish if the left
started with abolishing the atf every
conservative would be like yes
we could totally find common ground on
that absolutely let's get rid of the irs
etf yeah
where where is the left and abolishing
the irs it's like leftist
i know you're all in favor of like
taxation and stuff like that
but it is a government institution can
we agree to get rid of that one yeah or
the fed
yeah we'll start with this and then
we'll work our way up and we'll find
where we hit that wall keep finding
common ground atf goes
you know maybe some of these you know
agencies within dhs maybe we stop
somewhere and then you guys get rid of a
bunch of government institutions we keep
some of them it's a win-win
i want to kind of get rid of homeland
security didn't exist 30 years ago i
don't think it needs to exist now they
just created it after 9 11. no no it
it it brought things together so it all
it it took a bunch of different agencies
and put them on put them under one roof
it's like the secret police
they're like the dss of the german reich
no that's
that's totally unnecessary we already
have the national guard we have like the
department of defense we don't need
some new weird organization that's like
quasi-paramilitary
like we should like the federal
government should have it shouldn't have
its own police force
definitely not why not what because it
doesn't
who they who do they adhere to what do
you mean like who do they
who what jurisdiction is going to make
sure they don't get out of line
what federal government what do you mean
like what about any police officer then
who's going to stop any cop from getting
out of line the city the state
and so the feds have those same
jurisdictions the federal police doesn't
like answer to the state though that's
the problem yes they do
well technically maybe it's
jurisdictional debates
so in washington dc for instance and on
federal jurisdiction
you need federal police like if a dude
shows up with a gun
and starts shooting in dc who's gonna
arrest him i remember
how the left is super pro fbi and feds
now
like when i was on the left we hated
snitches
hated the fbi and now all of a sudden
they're like retweeting the fbi
asking for snitches and i'm like
you guys are really chasing homeland
security what's that that's another
department
homeland security is the parent for a
bunch of different divisions
like i think ice is within dhs right fps
yeah
uh um cbp we need customs and border
protection bro
otherwise you get people kidnapping
children
we need federal uh um was it federal
police service is what it's called in
washington d.c
they have federal police it's a federal
jurisdiction there would like
to be honest i don't know a lot about
dhs except that it didn't exist in 1998
and we were totally fine
we got disconnected weird we did
yeah lame but it's still recording i
mean we weren't fun we got
what's up itunes where did centers got
knocked down
i i i someone was aggro about what i was
talking about
i was speaking there's an atf guy and
he's calling nsa and he's like
just a little the nsa is another weird
one that didn't used to exist either
yeah definitely definitely creepy yeah
yeah we could team up on certainty yeah
yeah we just won't do it because
i'm just i'm just saying like dhs
includes that's what i was saying some
departments
with some some agencies within dhs
because dhs is just
a parent umbrella for a bunch of
organizations like we need
we got we're getting kicked off i think
we're probably getting ddosed it's weird
oh interesting
yeah because uh we were talking about
the atf they're mad
that's all it is maybe well we bought
attacked when i was
waiting on about waco the other day
listen we have triple redundancy on the
internet right now
so for those that are listening online
if you know we're cutting in and out i'm
not entirely sure
we have a triple redundancy on the
internet we have a really robust system
that was built
and yes by this really smart feller
that's right
and when one network goes down it
switches rapidly so we never get kicked
off for us to
actually get booted off right now yeah
that's pretty wild
conspiracy is abound no it's not a
conspiracy there there have been a
variety of cyber attacks going on yes
they've been having
fun we know that gab got attacked
recently yeah so thanks for checking out
this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time